michel onfray philosophe essayiste
auteur de grandeur du peuple et du petit
peuple chez albin michel michel onfray
bonjour jours merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation directe sur arte france
nouvelle journée de grève donc
aujourd'hui qui sont les manifestants
qu'on voit dans la rue des courageux qui
continue à s'engager pour un meilleur
avenir
ou alors des bornes et qui n'ont pas
suffisamment écouté le gouvernement dans
cette idée que les gens seraient des
crétins et n'aurait rien compris qu'il
faudrait expliquer que c'est un défaut
de pédagogie qui fait que les gens sont
mécontents c'est prendre les gens pour
des imbéciles
le peuple a très bien compris du mois
des gens qui manifestent ont très bien
compris à quoi ressemble cette réforme
d'abord faite une décision de bruxelles
et il s'agit juste de faire payer les
plus modestes comme d'habitude et
d'épargner les gens les plus riches donc
c'est le principe
donc les gens ont bien compris pas
besoin de voir faire un long tour de
france pour leur expliquer que n'ont pas
compris le quai à prendre à des débats
techniques pour essayer de perdre les
gens n'ont-ils les gens ils ont compris
véritablement ce que ce que c'est alors
il ya le fait que effectivement seuls
quelques uns peut faire la grève
déjà parce qu'ils perdent de l'argent et
sont pas remboursés contrairement à ce
qu'on dit beaucoup mais peuvent pas se
faire virer
donc effectivement que faire la grèce
mais le privé ne peut pas si vous dites
moi je travaille je passais de chez un
épicier je dis aujourd'hui je fais grève
d'hier à demain ne vous êtes à la porte
et puis c'est tout donc il ya des gens
qui sont un peu une espèce date d'avant
garde éclairée je dirais des
manifestants qui manifestent pour
d'autres qui ne le peuvent pas parce
qu'il se fait mettre à la porte
mais qui pense effectivement que ces
manifestations sont légitimes c'est un
système social issu du golo communisme
après la révolution de la rémission
après l'avis de la libération et c'était
effectivement un système un système
équitable qui permettait à certains en
cotisant de payer les retraites d'autres
qui des partis à la retraite etc
donc il faut évidemment repenser un
certain nombre de choses peut pas
imaginer que démographie été modifiées
comme elle l'est les choses devraient
fonctionner comme en 1944 45
mais pour autant on voit bien dans
quelle direction ça va et les gens qui
sont dans la rue ce sont des gens
lucides qui ont compris qu'il fallait
défendre
peut-être une réforme mais pas celle là
alors vous publiez un auteur du petit
peuple vous défendez le moment des
gilets jaunes
on envoie quelques uns tout de même des
gilets jaunes dans ces grèves ou vous
expliquer pourquoi ils sont pas si
nombreux que ça il ya quelques instants
quelle différence les gens qui étaient
sur les ronds-points ya plus d'un an qui
était-il par rapport à ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui défilé à paris j'utiliserai
si vous permettez des catégories de marx
je dirais il y avait un sous prolétariat
c'était le gilet jaune du départ les
jets les jaunes du de terre-plein du
rond-point de la périphérie était la
france périphérique elle était aussi à
la périphérie des villes et puis
aujourd'hui avec les gens qui descendent
dans la rue on a plutôt le prolétariat
le prolétariat ses hommes politiques à
ces syndicalistes cgt la cfdt journaux
l'humanité il ya des ratés des
représentants à l'assemblée nationale
alors que le sous prolétariat n'a rien
ni personne
je suis un des rares dont il est l'un
des rares à les avoir soutenus à les
soutenir encore en avait au contraire
surgir les éditorialistes et
journalistes certain nombre de
philosophes de sociologues etc
tout de suite on dit antisémitisme
xénophobie racisme etc pour discréditer
ces gens dont la demande était
extrêmement simple c'était de la dignité
il voulait juste de la dignité quand on
leur a dit on va augmenter le prix de
l'essence augmenté le prix du fuel ils
ont juste dit mais on ne peut plus on
veut bien mais on ne peut plus on paie
déjà des impôts on paie des impôts il
tout le monde pas d un point d impôts
indirects et tout le monde on paie des
impôts et en même temps on n'a pas de on
a pas de transports en commun dans les
andes dans les campagnes on a pas
d'école on n'a pas de les hôpitaux
ferment et c'est donc on n'en peut plus
et puis c'était peu avant noël et jean
dimond n'a pas d'argent pour payer des
jouets à nos enfants à noël c'était ça
la demande
on peut dire elle est trivial et les
vulgaires mais pas du tout c'est une
demande politique sont juste des gens
qui disent aux secours nous n'avons plus
les moyens de survivre
c'est même pas de vivre comme fait
marquant ces violences notamment à l'arc
de triomphe
on se souvient à ce moment là les gilets
jaunes donc sont montrés comme comme des
casseurs
ça a été une volonté selon vous de les
montrer du doigt bien ce moment là bien
sûr parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on parle
de l'arc de triomphe on a associé sa le
vandalisme et on les a associés au gilet
jaune
moi j'ai recherché il ya peu les images
que j'ai vues quand j'étais dans la
télévision le jour même ces images on ne
les voit plus or on entend un certain
nombre d'individus qui ne portent pas de
gilet jaune on attend dé moi je m'en
souviens avec des accents qui montrait
que la plupart un certain nombre d ordre
n'avait pas des accents de corse
bourguignon berrichon normands ou ou
alsacien est donc effectivement il ya
quelque chose qui s'est joué ici avec le
consentement du pouvoir il s'agissait
effectivement de salir les gilet jaune
d'associer les gilet jaune à ça la
preuve c'est que pour ce livre j'ai
cherché l'iconographie qui m'a permis la
couverture et j'ai tapé arc de triomphe
tags etc vous avez plein de photos de
l'arc de triomphe avec un tag gilet
jaune vaincrons un tag tout le monde se
souvient que le lac ne triomphe était
constellée de table pourquoi la palette
graphique at elle permis d'effacer la
totalité des détails sauf celui ci vous
aviez d'état qui était franchement
d'ultragauche le fameux avec un rond et
que michel wievorka sociedad le
sociologue officielle des socialistes et
du pouvoir pour nous dire que c'était un
signe d'extrême droite c'est le signe
des anarchistes
ben moi que les anarchistes aussi des
gens d'extrême droite mais il s'agissait
donc de dire y'a pas ultra gauche ya pas
eu de black blocks
il n'y a pas eu de guerre des banlieues
tout ça c'est la sphère du gilet jaune
et puis à l'époque il suffisait juste de
métal gilet jaune pour est un gilet
jaune
maintenant quand vous parlez de l'arc de
triomphe pourquoi ne dites-vous pas en
même temps je vous reproche pas à une
espèce de considérations générales que
ce sont aussi les gilet jaune qui se
sont opposés à ces prétendus chez les
jaunes pour éviter qu'on salisse la
mémoire du soldat inconnu ils ont sauvé
la flamme la d'ombré la flamme moi
j'étais avec ma web tv j'ai des contacts
avec des gens qu'ils m'envoient des
informations et notamment un policier
qui dit moi j'étais là je les ai vus ils
nous ont aidés nous la police la
gendarmerie à faire des thèmes centraux
puisse protéger la tombe la tombe du
soldat inconnu et la flamme du soldat
inconnu le dit on jamais il faut quelque
chose de pavlovien
gilet jaune arc de triomphe
vandalisation mais personne ne dira
qu'ils ont été les vandales
réfléchissons et revenons sur les bandes
elles sont quand même extrêmement
intéressante
et puis personne ne dit non plus que des
gilets jaunes ont fait ça c'est à dire
sauver la flamme du soldat inconnu
ça ne veut pas dire pour autant que
c'était tous les gilets jaunes je veux
dire que si on veut vraiment faire
correctement son travail il faut arrêter
de dire que les gilets jaunes ce sont
des casseurs et des vandales je vous dis
que ces tags qui ont totalement disparu
de 2,2 de l'arc de triomphe gilet jaune
vaincrons j'invite tous nos tous nos
auditeurs tous les téléspectateurs
allaient vérifier c'est assez sidérant
il ya même des gens qui m'ont dit oui
parce que ils ont nettoyé jc formidable
la ville de paris nettoie tout sauf ce
tag la danse et de la palette graphique
on a tout enlevé il s'agit juste de dire
il n'y avait que c'est faux merci
beaucoup michel en prêt d'avoir accepté
notre invitation je rappelle que vous
êtes philosophe essayiste et auteur de
grandeur du petit peuple chez albin
michel